-Adam, welcome, welcome
-Thanks, man.
-to "The Tonight Show."
Thanks for coming on.
It's great to see you.
I heard that
you actually just came back
from Italy.
-Yeah, like just
right before I came here.
We were in Tuscany for a wedding
that Dakota Johnson was not at.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, yeah, she should've
showed up at that.
-It wasn't the one
-It wasn't the one.
-that she crashed.
-She picks one a year
that she crashes, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Once in a lifetime,
she'll crash a wedding.
-One lucky couple every year.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It wasn't that one.
Oh, Tuscany must've
been beautiful.
-Yeah, yeah, it's beautiful.
-I've never been there.
I want to go.
-Oh, really?
We went to Florence and we go --
Whenever we go
to any foreign country,
my wife, Naomi,
she's really good about --
She's one of those people that
like brushes up on the language
and is like essentially fluent
-Wow.
-by the time we get there.
-Oh, cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Which is great
because everyone like comments
on how good she is
and she gets us around.
But also, I'm just such --
I'm such an idiot
[ Laughter ]
because I don't --
I don't know anything.
Like I don't know --
I struggle like saying --
I don't even know a word.
-One word.
-No.
And so I always like find myself
and it's so lame
and so embarrassing,
but I always --
I always end up like --
like saying English words
with like a terrible --
like an approximation
of an accent.
[ Laughter ]
Like the other day,
I really find myself saying,
[ Changing accent ]
Uh, yes, uh.
Do you -- Do you have a, uh,
a phone charger?
Yes, um.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, please."
And the guy's like,
"Do you need a phone charger?
I can just get you
[ Laughter ]
a phone charger."
-You're the one with the for--
[ Changes accent ]
How you say --
How do you say phone?
Grazie, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
-Oh, it's so bad.
-We were talking backstage
and we were talking
about you said that you met one
of your favorite actors
of all time,
the great Al Pacino.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I've never gotten to meet
Al Pacino.
-You haven't met Al Pacino?
-No, but I love Al Pacino.
-Oh, my God.
-He's one of my faves as well.
-Yeah. He's like my very
fave -- You know, actors,
you know, it's Al Pacino.
-That's your guy.
-Yeah, he's my guy
and he's kind of the guy
and we were at the
Vanity Fair Oscar party,
which is like all famous --
Like it's the place you go
if you want to feel less famous
[ Laughter ]
because they're all there.
-Everyone's there.
-[Both] Yeah.
-And I was talking
to Kevin Bacon,
which is also very cool,
and he was like,
"Hey, I was just talking
to Al Pacino."
And I was like, "Oh!
Al Pacino's here?"
He's like,
"Yeah, he's right over there.
You should go check it out.
Check out Al Pacino."
[ Laughter ]
That's my guy!
-That's your dude.
-And so I grabbed Naomi,
I grabbed my wife,
and I'm like,
"Let's go look at Al Pacino."
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to like talk
to him.
-No, of course not.
-No. What would I say?
-It's like the Mona Lisa.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-You just want to go look at it.
-Take a gander.
-Take a gander at Al Pacino.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. So, she's like,
"Oh, come on."
So we go over and I find
this spot like 15 yards.
[ Laughter ]
Sure enough, he's right there.
He's on like this couch
with a bunch of people.
And I find us spots like
under a potted palm tree,
[ Laughter ]
so we're kind of hidden
and I'm just like, "Let's just
look at him for five minutes
and then we can go."
-Get outta here, yeah.
-And so we're there and I'm
like, "It's him. He's there."
And I see him.
I kind of glance. I'm like,
"Yeah, he's there." There he is
and he's talking to people.
Take another look over.
He's still there. It's awesome.
And then it was like
the third time I looked,
it was like a horror movie
or something because,
the third time I look,
he's just looking right at me.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Oh!"
And not only is he looking
at me,
he like looks at me
and then he starts getting up
and walks over like one of those
ottoman/foot rest things,
this giant thing.
And he's like climbing over it,
[ Laughter ]
coming straight at us.
And I'm like, "Al Pacino.
He's coming.
He's coming. Al Pacino is like
walking over to us."
-Yeah.
-Sure enough, he comes right up
and he's like --
I can't --
I don't really do a Pacino.
You do, right?
-I could try, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, okay. He goes --
[ As Pacino ]
Oh, I -- I-I love your show.
So.
-[ As Pacino ] I love your show!
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
I love Sev--
"Severance"?
-"Severance."
"I love 'Severance.'"
-"I love 'Severance'"?
Al Pacino said that to you?
-He said, "I love 'Severance'
and my son and I watch it
together."
Yeah, I know.
[ Laughter ]
-What you did say back to him?
-I was like, "You have no idea.
I was here --
I just wanted to look at you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And --"
-This is a bonus.
-I was like,
he'll never believe me,
but, "That's what I was doing
here, was looking at you."
And I'm like, "Because you're
my guy, you're the best one."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-You're my favorite?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You got to say that to him?
-Yeah, I said it to him.
-Good for you.
-Yeah.
-Brought a photo, which I asked.
Here's a photo of you
and Al Pacino right there.
-Yeah.
-The one and only.
-That's the moment, right there.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-He asked me for a photo.
It was crazy.
-How cool is that?
-It was pretty cool.
-Everyone loves "Severance,"
by the way. Congrats.
The reviews,
rave reviews on the show.
-Oh, thank you.
-We had Ben Stiller on the show
for "Severance" when it first --
He directed a few episodes.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You crush it in this show.
It's so good.
-Thanks. Thank you.
-Congrats on the success of it.
It just got picked up
for Season 2.
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Thank you.
-It's so --
It's such a great idea
and it's so well-executed.
Congrats on that.
-Thanks.
-Can you describe --
How do you describe the show
to people?
-It's weird.
It's like it's sort of
a workplace thriller
sort of comedy,
where it takes place in a world
where Lumon Industries is this
company who has this technology.
Insert a microchip
into your brain, so,
when you cross the threshold
at your work, at your job,
suddenly, you don't know who you
are in the outside world.
It separates your memories
so all you know is work.
And then when you leave work
at the end of the day,
it deactivates the chip,
so you have no memory
of who you are at work
or what you did there.
So it just completely separates
your two realities,
work and life.
-Yeah. And it's so well done.
It's so well shot
and it gets tricky
and you're fantastic in it.
-Thanks, man.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Adam Scott
in "Severance." Take a look.
-Clearly, he was trying
to tell you something.
-Uh, no.
-Go lick a boob, Mark.
You're more loyal to this place
than to your friend.
-I'm loyal to how it felt
around here
before you showed up.
-You mean when Petey was here?
-Yeah, because there
was balance.
We could have fun and work
without the whole
[bleep] department imploding.
-Work is [bleep].
-The work is mysterious
and important
and we deal with the uncertainty
it brings us
in the way that Kier
would've wanted --
together, as a family.
-I could not,
with a razor to my throat,
be less interested
in being your family.
-Oh!
Come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Adam Scott, everybody!
"Severance" is streaming now
on Apple TV+.
Carrie Underwood performs
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.